[موسيقى]
نحن لم نبدا الحرب لكننا سننهيها وهولندا
تتجه لتصبح عدو روسيا الاول فما القصه
بينما اعلن الروس عن مواجهه عسكريه جويه
ضد الامريكان والاوروبيون يطالبون بتسديد
ثمن الفاتوره والولايات المتحده تدير
ظهرها تاركه لدى الاوكرانيه والمستشار
الالماني يعلن موعد انضمام اوكرانيا
للاتحاد الاوروبي طباخ بوتين يرفض هديه
بوتين الرئاسيه كما هو السبب يا بريجوجن
واوروبا تصارح اوكرانيا بهذه الكارثه
العسكريه وتهديد امريكي شديد اللهجه
للسودان وعمران خان حر طليق مره اخرى
اوروبا تعلنها في وجه اوكرانيا
وعندما وضع الغرب ثقله العسكريه في
الميزان الاوكراني ظلت كفه الروس ثابته لا
تميل والكفه الاوكرانيه تتارجح اكثر فاكثر
ليعلنها رئيس الوزراء الهنغاري فيكتور ان
اوكرانيا لا تمتلك فرصه للانتصار لم يرسل
النيتو قواته الى ارض المعركه اي ان اوربا
يعترف بخساره اوكرانيا ما لم يتدخل النيتو
بعدته واعتاده وجنوده وهناك وجه اوربان
بوصله نحو واشنطن قائلا لا نريد ان تعلمنا
الولايات المتحده كيفيه العيش قربا لم
يتوقف عن اطلاق سهامه على الغرب ليصرح هذه
المره بان فكره فرض الحزمه الحاديه عشره
من العقوبات الاوروبيه على روسيا امر
يتعارض مع الفطره السليمه لتصل الرساله
الهنغاريه الى الاوروبيين حيث اعلنا مفوض
سياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف
بوريل فشل وزراء الدفاع في الاتفاق على
حزمه مساعدات عسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا
مضيفا ان المناقشات بهذا الشان مستمر ما
الذي يجري في بروكسل ولماذا فشل الاتحاد
بالاجماع على العقوبات يا له من امر غريب
الاجابه تاتي من النيتو حيث قال الامين
العام للحلفين ان حرب اوكرانيا قد
استنزفتهم وان لم يرفع الحلف انتاجه
العسكري فالحرب الاوكرانيه محكوم عليها
بالفشل لانها معركه لوجستيه كما قال وهنا
تنضم الولايات المتحده الى قافله الافلاس
العسكري في مخازن الذخيره والاسلحه لتعلن
صحيفه هيلف ان التمويل العسكريه الامريكيه
لاوكرانيا قد يتوقف مؤقتا الى اجل غير
مسماه بسبب المناقشات المستمره في
الولايات المتحده بشان سقف الدين الوطني
وذلك بعد ان وصل حجم دين واشنطن الى الحد
الاقص المحدد وهو
31.381 تريليون دولار ليس ذلك فحسب حيث
ذكرت صحيفه بوليتيكو انه منذ بدايه
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه مدى سياسيون
الاوكرانيون بقياده الرئيس بوليود
للاعمال التجاريه في البلاد اي ان مسؤولي
الحكومه الاوكرانيه بقياده
يتاجرون بالحرب لملئ ارصدتهم من الدعم
الغربي وفق الصحيفه الامر يزداد سوءا على
الاوكران وهنا عدا بوريل ليقول ان الدول
الاتحاد الاوروبي طلبت من قياده الاتحاد
تعويضات ماليه بقيمه عشره مليارات تعويض
عن توريد الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا فكيف ستدفع
ثمن الفاتوره ليعلنها المتحدث باسم
الرئاسه الروسيه
[موسيقى]
التي تزود اوكرانيا بالاسلحه تتورط اكثر
في النزاع فهل علق الغرب في الوحل الروسي
ليعود بيسكوب ويؤكد بان ضخ الاسلحه
الغربيه الى كييف بما في ذلك طائرات اف 16
لا يمكنه بتاتا تغيير الوضع بشكل اساسي في
ساحات القتال بينما كانت صحيفه قد ذكرت
نقلا عن مستشار وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
ريساك انه هولندا قد تصبح اول دوله تنقل
طائرات مقاتله من طراز اف 16 الى كياب
وبذلك ستدسه على خط روسيا الاحمر لتصبح في
مواجهه حتميه مع الدب الروسي مهلا مهلا
مهلا في زمن هتلر كان لهولندا نصيب الاكبر
من النيران الالماني واليوم يختلف الزمان
والسلاح وبضغطه زر قد يعيد بوتين هولندا
من الفعل الحاضر الى الماضي لنقل كان هناك
هولندا فهل ينفذ صبر الدب الروسي ليضغط
على الزر سهوا لكن وعلى عكس مجرى الاحداث
اعلن بودانوب رئيس الاستخبارات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه في حديث لقناه ان اتش كيا
تلفزيونيه اليابانيه مصرحا لدينا بالفعل
الحد الادنى الضروري من الاسلحه ولا
يلسعني الا ان اقوله ان الهجوم المضاد
سيبدا قريبا ومع اقتراب الهجوم الاوكرانيه
والمستشار الالماني يرمي الطعم امام
الاوكرانيين وذلك باعلانه ان اوكرانيا
ستصبح عضوا في الاتحاد الاوروبي فور
استعادتها اراضيها ومن الحرب البارده بين
الغرب وروسيا نعود الى سعير الحرب
الاوكرانيه حيث اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان قواتها تمكنت من القضاء على
الفصائل القوميه المتطرفه الاوكرانيه التي
كانت قد توغلت في مقاطعه بالجروب مؤكده
مقتل اكثر من 70
مسلحت اي علاقه لها بال في منطقه الروسيه
وهنا عاد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
ليذكر بان اوكرانيا لم تكن موجوده على
الخارطه وان السلطات السوفيتيه في موسكو
هي التي شكلت دوله سمتها اوكرانيه على
اراضي الامبراطوريه الروسيه ليضيف بوتين
بان روسيا لم تبدا الحرب لكنها تحاول
بمساعده مكتب العمليات الخاصه لانهاء
الحرب ضد الشعب الروسي الذي وجد نفسه بسبب
الظلم التاريخي خارج حدود وطنه الامه وذلك
وفق التعبير بوتين وفي بخمه يبدو ان النصر
الروسي هناك سيعمق الخلاف الذي تفجر سابقا
بين مجموعه باجنر ووزاره الدفاع الروسيه
يعتبر الطباخ بوتين مؤسس مجموعه باجنر ان
اوسيمه الشجاعه التي سيقلدها الرئيس
الروسي لمقاتل باجنر لحاجه لها اذا كان
الكرملين سيقلد مثلها من لم يشارك في
فهل يصمت بوتين طويلا امام تصريحات
اللاذعه للقياده الروسيه ومن الارض الى
السماء حيث اندلعت هناك مواجهه جويه
مباشره بين واشنطن وموسكو وذلك عندما
اعلنت الدفاع الروسيه ان مقاتله من طراز
27 اعترضت قاذفتين استراتيجيتين امريكيتين
من
طرازات تحلقان فوق بحر البلطيق حيث نجحت
في منعهما من امتياك الاجواء الروسيه بحسب
بيان الوزاره الروسيه الاحداث والتطورات
هنا هدوء حذر في الخرطوم وذلك مع ثريان
الهدنه بين الجيش والدعم السريع رغم تسجيل
اشتباكات متقطعه ليقول وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه انه اذا خلقت الهدنه في السودان
فلن يخفى ذلك عنهم وسيحاسب المسؤولون عن
انتاكها اع القوات البحريه الدوليه
المشتركه بقياده الولايات المتحده عن
انشاء فرقه عمل جديده الفرقه 154 لتعزيز
الامن البحري في الشرق الاوسط قال رئيس
اركان الكيانه
اكثر من اي وقت مضى مشيرا الى ان هذا قد
يدفع اسرائيل لشم عمل عسكري واكد رئيس
الاركان الاسرائيلي ان بلاده لديها القدره
على ضرب ايران وادرعها قررت محكمه مكافحه
الارهاب في اسلام اباد الافراج عن رئيس
الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران خان في
كفاله على ذمه محاكمته في ثماني قضايا
تتعلق بالعنف واثاره الاضطرابات
الغربيه لا يمنع قوات موسكو من التقدم
برايكم ما الذي استفاده الغرب بعد ان افرغ
مخازنه للاوكرانيين
[موسيقى]